you started coinbase when bitcoin was
ten dollars
yeah um
and you just mentioned an incredible
system with security with transactions
everything is thought through there's a
lot going on but what was version one
back in those early days the first
prototype of coinbase what did that look
like yeah like what what did it take to
write it
to think through it
and and uh make it work enough to at
least make you believe that it's going
to work
well i definitely didn't know if it was
going to work i mean it was kind of i
felt like i was just
following my gut so
i mean i was working at airbnb i was a
software engineer there
project manager i was working on some
fraud prevention stuff for instance
and um i read the bitcoin white paper in
kind of december of 2010
i started going to some bitcoin meetups
in the bay area
um met lots of interesting people there
like crazy people anarchists you know
like really brilliant people all the
above and so i started nights and
weekends trying to hack put together a
prototype and my initial thought was
well you know smtp is a protocol that
runs email and
you know git is is a protocol for
version control that and but people made
like gmail and github they don't most
people don't want to run their own email
server or even their own git server they
just want to like use a hosted thing
that you know will do all the security
and backups for them
so the thought in my head at that time
was bitcoin's this new protocol there's
probably going to be somebody who makes
a hosted service that does all the
security and backups for you makes
bitcoin as a protocol easy to use
so maybe i should
maybe i should make like a hosted
bitcoin wallet or something that would
that was my it was gonna make gmail for
bitcoin or something
and a bunch of people told me that was a
bad idea like bunch most of my smart
friends when i told about it they were
like
well first of all i don't really get
what you're doing at all like bitcoin
sounds like a scam or something you got
you've gotten involved in um
but then other people who understood
what bitcoin was told me i thought it
was a dumb idea because they're like
dude if you store all this bitcoin
you're just gonna get hacked like nobody
you know
why would you why would you do that
and so
i i kind of had this thought like you
know what i'm not going to go all in and
like make a story everyone's bitcoin
that would be too much right now i have
a job i have a day job you know
but let me just make a prototype and
i'll tell people this is like a beta
thing like don't put any real money in
it and just see if there's interest and
if i feel like i'm onto something maybe
i'll go do this as a company because i
did i really wanted to be an
entrepreneur at that time i was like
i was 29 i was almost turning 30 and i
was i always wanted to like start a
company but
i was i was you know i wasn't yet i was
an employee at a company that was great
but
so anyway i had this prototype i was
hacking together nice and weekends i
actually wrote a whole bitcoin node in
ruby which turned out to be a maybe a
weird decision in hindsight because ruby
wasn't the most performant language
we've subsequently had to rebuild that
many times but
yeah i had this hosted bitcoin wallet
and the thing that i didn't have any
users for it by the way i applied to y
combinator because i was like maybe if
somebody there writes me a check this
will like make it feel like a real
company and i was trying to find i was
trying to find a co-founder at that time
unsuccessfully
so i was basically just wandering in the
desert i had a lot of self-doubt about
this because i i was like i don't know
all my friends don't think's just kind
of dumb and
maybe bitcoin is just going to get shut
down and like this all be some stupid
thing so
there was definitely a feeling of just
wandering lost in the desert lots of
self-doubt
um paul graham and the y combinator
group kind of wrote me the first check
after i went and interviewed and stuff
and they they wrote me a check for like
150k and that was the first time
somebody who i really looked up to kind
of said this is this is worth pursuing
like maybe maybe you're onto something
maybe or not but like let's at least try
it
and so i that was kind of what gave me
the confidence to quit my job and try it
and
um i'll wrap the story here by saying
that like we i you know i found the
right co-founder after y combinator
we still didn't have any customers the
thing that you know i basically launched
the hosted bitcoin wallet
there were people signing up um i just
posted on reddit and places like that
and you know maybe like 100 people would
sign up and then nobody would come back
and so i was like i just in y commented
they often tell you like
you know talk to your customers and
improve your product talk to your
customers improve your product that's
all you're supposed to be doing try to
find product market fit so i emailed
like five of the users that had signed
up
and i was like hey i worked on this app
i saw you signed up can i get on the
phone with you i get on the phone with
like five of these folks and i was like
you know why didn't you come back and
the guy was like well the app was okay
for a for a beta but um like i don't
have any bitcoins so i didn't really
know what to do with it
and i remember this light bulb kind of
went off my head i was like well if i
put a buy bitcoin button in there uh
would you have used it and he was like
yeah maybe
so then i had this we went about the
process my co-founder at that time we
like got
basically had to get like a bank
partnership payment rails you know an
exchange basic exchange functionality
all that stuff i was mentioning earlier
in place
and the minute we launched that feature
where you could just click buy put in
your bank counter credit card buy it buy
bitcoin it showed up in your account
from that day forward like the number of
users started go up like this and so we
finally had found product market fit
after two years of wandering in the
desert so you weren't even thinking
about to buy the
on-ramps you would think it would be
just the wall a place to store bitcoin
that you've already gotten
yeah okay this is i mean uh because
that's such a pain to do
to have to work with others
to convert dollars of any fiat currency
into
into bitcoin yeah so did you
i mean were you uh
overwhelmed by the immensity of the task
here or where you just
um
sort of not allowing yourself to think
too deeply through this whole thing and
just letting the optimism take over here
you know i was really looking forward to
like doing something crazy and like a
big challenge and um i wanted to
i i love kind of
crisis moments like that where you know
i'm very determined right especially
when i i get like very set on something
and i'm just like you know what i'm
gonna figure out a way to make this
[ __ ] thing work like no matter what
and so
i i reveled in that i i was sort of i
had i had read all these books about
startups and like every startup has
these like you know major setbacks and
just like nothing works and so
that was a sign that you're doing
something right i had no idea if i was
doing anything right at all but i was
like i was kind of loving the experience
of it in a weird way it felt
it felt stressful at the time like you
know nothing was working and
but i was just i felt like i was
on the right path somehow and so i just
kept going
you